[Music]
prepare for the 50th anniversary of the
Bond franchise with a new film by the
director whose most famous action scene
to date was this Skyfall the overrated
movie that thrilled audiences worldwide
only because it was way better than
quantum of solace suit up with
double-oh-seven
the super-secret mi6 agent who everyone
knows by his real name bond bond bond Mr
Bond
Mr Bond change in an opening so
action-packed you'll forget to ask
yourself why didn't the conductor stop
this train and its entire back carriage
was ripped off and why aren't these
people scared
when bond is abruptly killed it'll only
take the length of one Adele song before
he anti-climactic Lee pops-up in the
most secluded corner of the globe that
conveniently has CNN in English the bond
returns to the high-stakes world of
espionage he's faced with a word
association at sky office politics Prime
Minister's ordered an inquiry you'll
have to appear our theory
judi dench frowning
Oh
and absurdly long landscape shots meet
rasool ullah the pause villain we've
been waiting for because he doesn't show
up until halfway through the movie
and antagonist with a plan so complex he
wants to get caught but makes it nearly
impossible to find him knows months
ahead of time the exact place to plant
explosives during the chase he didn't
even know it's going to happen and makes
bond gay discover the latest and super
secret gadgetry like a gun a knife a
shotgun an old-timey gun dynamite and a
tracking device larger than the one bond
used in the 60s here's a nice little
transmitting device it fitted into the
heel of your shoe bond we'll use these
tools to hunt down a terrorist who stole
a list of secret agents the computer
drive containing the identity of almost
every NATO agent which the writer stole
from the part of mission impossible but
filled with actions so artsy you'll
strain to watch fight scenes shot in
total darkness
and ending so goofy they disrupted off a
ball alone
[Music]
and the helo so sexually aggressive
you'll wonder is any sort of raping that
former child prostitute Jesus
starring Jason bore and Fred from
scooby-doo Lindsay Lohan random Bond
girl number 732 this moneypenny's black
Gollum Santa Claus and sexy bald award
Skyfall wait whatever happened to that
hard drive they were looking for wasn't
that the whole point of the movie no
okay
make sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers and check out last week's
episode where we get some witches
bitching about the new action film
Hansel and Gretel witch hunters your
feet smell like popcorn I sunk your
battleship [ __ ] kamehameha your
bellybutton tastes like broccoli yummy